why does don't look up look like the
most hilarious and frustrating movie to
have ever been made it's packed with
a-listers a-listers who had to
quarantine together they might just be
the closest cast to have ever filmed
together which means lots of awesome
behind the scenes stories check it out
number one and we don't mean a kite here
jennifer lawrence was flying high as a
kite for one scene in the movie well we
don't condone the use of such substances
especially at work lawrence didn't
really have much to say her job was just
to react to whatever was thrown at her
and it was agreed upon by the director
and lawrence that the glassy-eyed look
would really add a certain element to
the scene i was so tempted to go on the
mic and say hey let's improvise a
monologue
adam mckay decided against it because it
was just too mean
number two nose rings often seem like a
good idea at first and then you realize
how much you need to stick your finger
up your nose to keep it straight and
that cool girl attitude suddenly
dissipates well things were a little
more awkward in jayla's case as she had
a magnet holding her nose ring in place
and she swallowed the thing and then to
make matters worse she recalls and had
to spit it
out
in front of leonardo dicaprio
yikes
[Music]
number three put it under your pillow
jen and more awkward mishaps poor
jennifer lawrence lost one of her
veneers from eating a sucker and she
couldn't get the tooth fixed because of
covid so they cgied it back meaning
frame by frame they added that sucker in
uh we mean the tooth i still don't get
it
j-law was probably forbidden from eating
suckers after that you'd think there'd
be at least one dentist on speed dial
for actors or a hollywood budget might
persuade them to say yes either way
we're grateful for cgi and the
painstaking work it must have been to
add and post
imagine if they didn't
number four sometimes the best costume
isn't the sexiest one now that the whole
world wants to sleep with you i don't
think that the whole i wasn't talking to
you susan matherson the costume designer
and jennifer lawrence worked together to
create her look for the movie they tried
all sorts of different wigs but lawrence
gravitated to the short banged style
because she just knew that was the
character when she saw it despite the
fact she knows there are a lot of people
out there who think the look is
hideous we personally find that it grows
on you and it turns out doing those
thick cat eyes on j-law was no easy feat
because the makeup artist would
constantly tell her how her eyes are not
the same size
so frustrating
number five don't worry it's just a
minor one guys
hey you
jennifer lawrence must have hurt the
feelings of a glass window when she
broke it because it lashed back and cut
her face poor jen from swallowing a
magnet losing a tooth and now cutting up
her face she really was having a rough
time on set but no major injuries were
reported although we did hear they had
to shut down production for an entire
day because of it
number six sign me up how much would you
pay to live in a house with jennifer
lawrence timote chalamet and leonardo
dicaprio priceless right because that's
what happened when they filmed during
peak coved turns out it was not the best
experience for lawrence we all had to
share a bathroom we can't help but be
curious who else was in the house with
them jonah hill meryl streep have you
heard was this like big brother all-star
they could have made a show and a movie
for the price of one
so we are paying them
why
number seven one chalamese freedom
another lawrence's nightmare once they
were all out of quarantine lawrence
recalls being driven crazy by cast
members chalamet and dicaprio it was a
weird energy on set that day since the
confinement shrank from a house to a car
i don't know what it was timothy was
just excited to be like out of the house
and apparently leo went on a spiel about
what song was playing in the car and
lawrence would have just preferred
silence you know this song was about you
know blah blah blah it can sometimes be
hard to decipher when she's being
sarcastic but we're pretty sure she
loves them and for jonah hill he was
thrilled to finally be filming for me i
felt like i was lit out of a cage and
for meryl streep she found it took her a
bit to get back into the swing of things
she found it hard to bring back the
playful nature and bring the
performances to life
number eight practice makes perfection
unless you're a writer then only
rewrites can do that it's no secret that
leonardo dicaprio is incredibly
passionate about climate change which
may just be the reason he took on the
project and the reason for the 15 plus
rewrites they had to do for one scene we
worked on that endlessly he had amy
masner the local astronomer talked to
them about the sense of frustration that
the scientific community has with trying
to articulate issues like climate change
so this is the project dicaprio wanted
to do to really honor the scientific
community
number 9.
how is it timote chalamet is in
literally every cool movie these days
how did he have time to film them all
from dune to the french dispatch and
don't look up all in 2021 and now he's
kissing j-law dang this boy gets around
the uh movies we mean but that's one
spicy kiss and if we didn't see that
camera in the corner of this shot we
might just think this scene was real so
uh okay maybe not we know she's got a
baby on the way with her loving
gallerist husband cook maroney but we've
got to say we love seeing lawrence
pushing her acting capabilities don't
get us wrong we loved the love triangle
moody katniss everdeen in the hunger
games but lawrence is capable of
characters with some real gravitas
number 10. genius or goofball jonah hill
was supposedly the worst to work with
according to lawrence the guy was just
so funny she kept breaking character an
entire day was dedicated to filming hill
just throwing insults at lawrence and
even meryl streep has some strong
feelings about jonah hill who kind of
was a thorn in my side he was so funny
he had the goat cracking up
number 11 could just be stockholm
syndrome so it's no secret that this
cast has a huge soft spot for each other
while it may just be stockholm syndrome
it could also just be a great group of
actors creating magic maybe it's a bit
of both jonah hill kept calling meryl
streep the goat and she was completely
unaware of the fact it's an acronym
meaning greatest of all time and i sort
of thought well you kind of look like a
goat and she didn't even get offended by
it while dicaprio thinks lawrence is the
meryl streep of this generation and
streep called her the beating heart of
this movie and no jonah hill did not
enjoy throwing insults at j-law i did
not enjoy making fun of jen cause i love
jen but he did enjoy making fun of
dicaprio because dicaprio likes to play
the suave character and felt incredibly
uncomfortable playing a nerd and meryl
remembers playing alongside dicaprio
when he was just a little baby or should
we say 18. and now she thinks he's the
best he's ever been in a career of highs
ugh so sweet
number 12.
for what happened last time leo had a
roll on a boat so the cast and crew got
to film on a real freaking battleship
for the movie the battleship
massachusetts in fall river and they had
fireworks going off it was a great
experience for the whole town to have
them filming there and a great
experience for the crew
which is not always the case stars
filled an entire parking lot and the
cast also got to shoot out of a real
cargo plane lawrence recalls it being
very cold
and that was tough but it was one of the
greatest days of my life
it sounds like filming don't look up was
a pretty wild experience when the whole
world was shut down for one end of world
event the cast was telling a whole other
apocalyptic story it's clear the movie
is a parallel to climate change the cast
have said so themselves and while this
movie tells it in such a lighthearted
way maybe it's time we listen up okay if
you had to quarantine with one of the
stars from the movie who would you
choose let us know in the comments
thanks for watching
[Music]